big story on the cultural front from
Britney Spears who has a book coming out
and in the book she says she had an
abortion when she was younger and while
she was dating Justin
Timberlake which you might recall was
all the media was talk the media was
were talking about Justin and Britney
for like half of my childhood I feel
like and uh apparently there was always
a big question did they or did they not
you know did they do that thing that
only married people are supposed to do
guess the answer was they did and
Britney then became pregnant and then
she says she had an abortion and she
said if if it had been left up to me
alone I never would have done it and yet
Justin was so sure that he didn't want
to be a father he said we weren't ready
to have a baby in our lives that we were
way too young to this day it's one of
the most agonizing things I've ever
experienced to my life to which I
say many such cases many such cases
there was a young woman who wrote Into
the show this was maybe years ago now
and she said hey Michael I'm I've got an
abortion appointment but I know you're
pro-life so what do you think should I
not do it and my my first response
was do not do not under any circumstance
go through with the
abortion you will regret it the rest of
your
life the reason not to have the abortion
is because you're killing your child the
reason not have the abortion is because
it's intrinsically unjust but if you're
trying to reach someone just on a very
emotional level even on a very selfish
level make it clear you will regret it
for the rest of your life I know a
number of women who have had abortions I
know some women who have had multiple
abortions it's very difficult for them
to get over it I'm not they never
totally get over it some of them have
healed and repented and moved on and
lived edifying sanctifying lives but
that's not something you really just
like Get
over and then Britney famous ly not that
long thereafter went completely crazy
and then was placed in a conservator
ship and still exhibits all these kind
of crazy
behaviors you think there might be a
connection
there I've seen that kind of connection
I think I suspect there strongly is it's
like lady MC Beth trying to wipe out the
the blood out damn
spot that's a that's a driver of that I
wonder as we see the explosion of
anxiety and depression and suicidality
and just psychosis among young women the
the the number of young women who have
to be prescribed all these powerful
psych meds right now I wonder if some of
that maybe much of that has to do with a
culture that encourages them to commit
actions that lead to such regret most
clearly abortion but the whole thing the
culture of promiscuity the hookup
culture feminism all the rest of it
might there be a connection between the
insanity that people are expressing men
too men too in a different way the
insanity that people seem to be
displaying today and the insane and
unreasonable behaviors that they engage
in that lead to such regret right now go
to jus.com
nsyt everyone here at the office loves
the Jus Cell Dark Spot Corrector you
might be asking what this product even
does well if you've got sunspots dark
spots discoloration or dry skin the genu
Cell Dark Spot Corrector will help those
blemishes disappear in front of your
very eyes Kimberly from youngst Ohio
says my appearance has improved so much
since using genus cell I love all my
genus cell products and my skin looks
younger now it's your turn to feel like
Kimberly but hurry this sale is ending
very soon take advantage of Jus cell's
most popular package which includes the
Beloved Dark Spot Corrector this package
also includes the genell classic under
eye treatment you will get all these
products for almost 70 70% off genus
cell is so confident in their products
that you can try them for yourself
completely risk-free if you don't see
immediate results you will get your
money back it's very simple go to Jus
cell.com nsyt start looking years even
decades younger tomorrow say goodbye to
dark and liver spots bags and puffiness
under the eyes crows feet at Jus
cell.com letter y letter T Jus cell.com
YT where does Jim Jordan's race
stand it's not looking great you know I
I love Jim Jordan the only reason that I
I didn't immediately endorse him for
speaker is because I like him too much
and I think he's a good guy and I think
being the Republican speaker of the
house is the worst job in Washington d
I'm sure he'd be great at it but I I
wouldn't wish that on my worst enemy
anyway Jim threw his hat in the ring and
he he ended up beating out Steve scales
Who first got the nomination then didn't
have the votes he dropped out of the
race now Jim Jordan's up he went up for
the vote and
lost and then they went up for a second
vote he lost again a total of 199
members voted for Jim Jordan yesterday
which means he Lo he lost by a greater
margin than he had the day before he
lost he ended up losing one additional
vote because he previously had gotten
200 votes the day before so now they're
22 Republican defectors voting for other
people in the
GOP uh hakee Jeff ended up getting more
votes 212 but not enough to elect him
speaker so now what are we going to do
well this was always the fear in fact I
think this is why Jim Jordan did not
vote to oust Kevin McCarthy is because
there wasn't much of a plan on who was
going to replace him Steve scales he
didn't have the votes Jim Geor doesn't
currently have the votes I hope he gets
them who what are they going to do one
possibility is to expand the powers of
the temporary house Speaker Patrick
McKenry so Patrick McKenry just by
default gets this position as the
temporary speaker of the house but he
doesn't really have virtually any of the
power of the speaker of the house so one
solution that's been proposed is to just
give him those Powers passed as a as an
act of Congress and then uh once he has
those Powers they can kind kind of get
through this term and then figure out
what happens in
2024 uh not ideal not a great way for
the Republicans to exercise power it
seems to me we've got a very slim
majority and uh We've Democrats have the
Senate Democrats have the White House
Democrats have the Deep State and the
media and the universities and virtually
every Power Center in the country so who
the hold outs on Jim Jordan 22 of them
they're virtually all
squishes maybe not every single pretty
much every single one of them though
they're squishes they're liberals
they're sabots they're they're just
awful and they need to get on board
because if they don't then the
Republicans will be seeding the very
little control that they currently have
in the government and maybe that's what
these squishes wanted the whole time
maybe that's what these limp Republicans
impotent Republicans always kind of
wanted the reason that being the
Republican speaker of the house is the
worst job in
the country in certainly in Washington
DC is because the Democrats are all on
the same page with the exception of Joe
mansion and maybe Kirsten Cinema they're
all Progressive leftists there there is
barely a blue dog left in the bunch so
they're all on the same page and they
can they can join together and act and
and throw their weight around because
they're unified the Republicans are not
the Republicans have conservatives the
Republicans have Libertarians the
Republicans have liberals the
conservatives have the the self-styled
moderates the conservatives have the
Chamber of Commerce people they're
they're disperate factions and they
don't have a ton bringing them together
so they're going to hang apart and what
these squishes are saying is they're
saying look I would rather give
Democrats much more control over the
House of Representatives and have nearly
unified control over the government then
Empower one of those mean old
conservatives Jim Jordan too by the way
because Jim Jordan has very conservative
beliefs but he is as respectable a guy
in Congress as there possibly could be
he is as decent a guy as you're going to
find
in the House of Representatives and if
he is too far and crazy and right-wing
for them then they're just not
conservative which means that the the
five person Republican majority was
largely
elusory because we weren't able to get a
speaker yes they kind of agreed on Kevin
McCarthy but the only way that Kevin
finally got his speakership the first
time the only time I guess is when he
conceited so much of his power that they
were able to depose him nine months
later basically the same thing happened
with Paul Ryan Paul Ryan was a
compromised candidate he didn't ask for
the job he wanted to remain chairman of
the budget committee he was drafted as
the only person who could bring the the
factions of the GOP together and then he
left in ignominy nobody liked him by the
time he left how about uh John Boehner
John Boehner deeply unpopular speaker no
one likes him now he basically just
shills for Democrats while he's sipping
red wine and smoking a Sig on the cover
of his tellall book bashing
conservatives we just don't we just
don't have any ability to function as
Republicans at the national level in
Washington DC one of the reasons I was a
little skeptical of Ting McCarthy
although that it was that that fate was
sealed the moment that McCarthy made his
deal with the conservatives to become
speaker in the first place so where do
we go from here we either go to speaker
Jordan or we lose a lot of power that's
where we go boy what a great clip that
was now h h Huh huh bring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael nolles YouTube
channel we'll see you next time